George Bush the Cheerleader... and 9 Other
Celebrity Facts
1) Viggo Mortensen broke two toes while filming
the scene where he kicks the helmet by the
pyre in Lord of the Rings, The Two Towers,
thinking Marry and Pippen were dead.
Because of his realistic cry of anguish after
kicking the helmet and breaking his toes,
Peter Jackson chose that take to include in
the movie.
2) In Alfred Hitchcock’s movie, Psycho,
the shower scene was made up from 90 different
shots using 70 different camera angles.
The entire movie only took six weeks to shoot,
however, that one shower scene took just over
1 week to complete.
So what does one week worth of work, and 90
shots from 70 camera angles get you?
Only 45 seconds of footage that made it into
the film.
3) The Hollywood walk of fame not only has
the biggest stars we all know and love, but
it also has a few fictional cartoon characters.
The first fictional character to have his
name on the Hollywood walk of fame, was Mickey
Mouse on November 18, 1978.
Other cartoon characters to earn stars include,
Bugs Bunny, Donald Duck, Woody Woodpecker,Snow
White, Tinker Bell, Winnie The Pooh, Shrek,
The Rugrats, and The Simpsons.
4) The Flintstones pilot episode came out
in 1959, as a 90 second clip to draw advertisers
to the show.
At the time, it was called “The Flagstones.”
and was intended to be a show for adults,
not kids.
In fact, the first two full seasons of the
show were sponsored by Winstons, a cigarette
company.
5) Just three months after his death, Charlie
Chaplin’s body was stolen on Christmas day
in 1977, by two mechanics.
They thought they could get money from his
family in exchange for his body.
However, the two grave robbers were captured
eleven weeks later and Chaplin’s body was
recovered.
To stop this from happening again, Chaplin
was buried under 6 feet of concrete the second
time around.
6) George W. Bush was the head cheerleader
at Phillips Academy boarding school during
his senior year of high school.
At the time, it was an all-male school.
7) The character of “George Bailey” on
“It’s a Wonderful Life” was partially
based on the founder of Bank of America.
8) Moe Howard (Moe from the three stooges)
was once a Shakespearian actor, first doing
this after dropping out of school and joining
a Shakespearian acting troupe that performed
on the riverboat, Sunflower.
9)“Play it again, Sam” was never said
in Casablanca.
Furthermore, although many attribute the adapted
version to Bogart, the closest thing to it
comes from Bergman’s character, Ilsa, who
says, “Play it once Sam… for old time’s
sake….
Play it, Sam.
Play, ‘As Time Goes By’.“
10) Jamie Lee Curtis’ primary claim to fame
is her acting career, but she also invented
a new type of diaper in 1987.
Curtis proudly stated about her patented invention
(Patent No. 4,753,647), “It’s a disposable
infant garment which takes the form of a diaper
including, on its outer side, a sealed, but
openable, moisture-proof pocket which contains
one or more clean-up wipers.”